hey what's up everybody welcome to the
are you garbage comedy podcast please
take a second to subscribe to the
YouTube channel that way you get the
episodes as they come out thanks a lot
welcome to another exciting edition of
ru garbage the show where you find out
if your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast
this is ru garbage the show where we sit
down with your favorite comedians and
find out if they grew up classy or if
their absolute trash I'm your host stage
Foley coming at you on a beautiful
cloudy day here in Astoria Queens my
good pal and co-host hot tails out of
town at the first sign of trouble cuz
riding out the pandemic at an
undisclosed location somewhere in the
very classy Wildwood New Jersey our good
pal ladies and gentlemen Kevin James
Brian everybody oh baby down here in
casablanca studios and loving every
minute of it it's him doom and gloom
down here though for sure it ain't it
ain't looking pretty but happy to be
here thanks so much guys for tuning in
we really appreciate it thank you for
rating reviewing subscribing you do that
on iTunes Spotify and the full video is
up on YouTube we appreciate it and also
everybody sending in their own ru
garbage questions which we appreciate
you can set them to ru garbage at
gmail.com thanks every nice campy thank
you so much and we have a very special
guest today one of my absolute favorites
I know when a kippis absolute favorites
we're gonna lead off this again another
[ __ ] laundry list of credits here we
got big guests on this show and I love
it as far as acting wise you see them on
billions you seen him on inside Amy
Schumer his stand-up comedy credits are
unbelievable you got The Tonight Show
you have his first special Cassidy just
called like a [ __ ] idiot
you have his first special positive
influence last call Carson Daly this
week at the Comedy Cellar The Late Late
Show with James Corden lights out with
David Spade his brand new special which
is absolutely fantastic called I got
the Conan O'Brien show ladies and
gentlemen that is all well and good but
we're here to find out is he garbage I
say absolutely no way Leviathan samer el
everybody thank you we all are a little
right I mean it's funny I think I think
I must have been one of the last
episodes of David Spade before it got
canned because it got can't so soon
after I was on that you feel like a
little guilt yeah what lights out they
owe that spot is poison that like that
11:30 spot for like since Colbert once
he left it was like you're gonna last
two months at best yeah nothing that
[ __ ] was actually awesome and and plus
they had so many things that they could
cut up and release digitally
I just yeah but I think you know I mean
we can get into this another time but
Comedy Central's got some issues just
laid off like everybody there it said
it's horrible but it started selling
salsa last couple I always said this and
I know we get we gave you know when we
have a comic-con Sam it means that we
really love them with really respect
what they do I always thought when I
would watch to see the the week at the
cellar I mean I think you're one of the
best like pure comedians pure joke
writers especially in New York City and
I used to think to myself if I was
running that operation but I give this
[ __ ] kid the TV show everybody else
everybody else would just say something
topical and then jump into a bit from
like 12 years ago Trump versus Biden
anyway like my grandpa grandpa yeah dude
it I missed that show more than anything
mostly because it just it just makes you
write jokes it just keeps you
it just keeps you current and it's like
you know for someone with a DD as bad as
I have you need a homework assignment to
kind of steer you in the right direction
so I miss that show so much I thought I
thought you were [ __ ] great on it man
and I think you dude it's a topical
because you don't have to give anything
away personal that's gonna like hurt
like you are sometimes you give away
like a purse
no joke - like a - like a set and you're
like well no one's ever gonna see that
it hurts that that's kind of like gone
but but a topical joke you don't really
give a [ __ ] about like that's that was
Tuesday you know yeah that wasn't that
wasn't gonna make in six months or
whatever you know yeah exactly you know
I was just selling Foley that I wouldn't
they did a terrible show in Pennsylvania
five years ago and the guy did - Lorena
Bobbit joke and I was like Jesus
afterwards he goes it was a good joke
twenty two years ago it's a good joke
today
oh no it's not oh so guess what other
women have cut men's dicks off since
then just joy just set up yeah yeah just
change all these remember Lorena Bobbitt
you say [ __ ] another guy's dick got
cut off and like all right that's like
now it's like three years old you know
yeah exactly can just put a put a little
polish on it you know what I mean
I like I said cut that part off I saw
the porno that guy did after that
happened to him
still had a pretty decent piece on him
[Music]
yeah it was him and they drain the whole
storyline I don't know if he got [ __ ]
life rights for it or what but it was
like him in a hospital bed like
recovering from this injury and then
this nurse came into work that was a
little tiny pee pee it wasn't it wasn't
great but for getting slashed off still
a pretty decent little resell value on
that thing so Sam this is are you
garbage we've had some of your cronies
on here some of your boys on here and I
gotta say yeah you got Paul virzi you
got Joe list you got mark Norman Bobby
Kelly all trash they're all garbage or I
could've totally I could have saved you
but you I have a lot of hope for here
really well the t-shirts not helping me
I was expecting a suit and tie Oh Upper
East Side kid right yeah grew up on the
Upper East Side yeah straight let's
Upper East Side in the 90s to Kippy
there's a lot of cash
that's old money out there oh yes so
just tell us a little bit like well what
was it like so--you you were a pure city
kid what did your mom and dad do my
mom's an artist my dad's a lawyer he
worked for Viacom Jesus yeah yeah he was
doing a lot of like copyright stuff so
you know ironically my dad would be I'd
be like fighting against my dad now
because I've been illegally uploading so
many clips from Comedy Central which is
a part of Viacom yeah wrapped in letter
cease and desist orders so I really I
will call my dad and be like can I get
in trouble for this no Billy probably
not like I will actually like go to him
he is my lawyer like I have friends like
mark Normand has a lawyer my marks dad
is also a lawyer you know so I don't
know if Mark uses his dad though I use
my dad because he knows about
Entertainment Law so I and people have
told me not to do that because they're
like well you know if he [ __ ] up a deal
could hurt your relationship and I'm
like with my dad okay yeah yeah look
what happened a Billy Joel next thing
you know your old man's sailing away
with 40 million of your money that's
true well yeah so yeah originally like I
guess it's Flatiron now but I called it
Chelsea growing up I was originally
Chelsea then I was Upper East Side my
mom married my dad a product of a
blended family so he's technically my
stepdad okay and I call him dad he's a
great dad and I yeah a brother and
sister who are stepbrother and
stepsister but you know you just I was
so young man I was like probably when
they met probably like three or four and
they got married and I was like seven
remember exactly my name was I was Sam
Greenberg you know like how how Julianne
act was all over baby Greenberg coming
at ya I would have changed my first name
to Shecky you know it's like it would
have been harder to play the Midwest
back I might even be hard to play the
Midwest now what's the way Sam you know
so it was to me was like it's a
different vibe it's like that's why you
know I'm always fascinated to have city
kids on the show because it is such a
different thing and it's I mean there's
garbage in it and like like to say to
say that like your mom got remarried and
stuff like that you could look at step
that step mom stuff like that as trashy
but when you're dealing with the
entertainment lawyer an artist it kind
of raises the class a little bit well
that's that's the kind of [ __ ] you see
in the city well we had I had a
biological father leave for that
definitely if we're talking about that
you don't see that in Manhattan
stereotypically bridge-and-tunnel right
there dude you have a very man hat I
mean even like you'll like my mom's an
artist my dad's an entertainment lawyer
I grew up in Chelsea or flat that's like
that's like the beginning of like a bad
movie that's like what a bad script
writer would you like she's an artist
he's a lawyer they live like I can't
sell a [ __ ] TV show it's very
ignorant engines vibe from me well in a
good way man
yeah I mean I'm loving that movie as a
kid I hit me right at the right age then
and then I read Dangerous Liaisons years
later only this movie [ __ ] sucks but
uh you know yeah you know I went to like
a preppy Upper East Side school and you
went to a private school right I did
yeah all right I here's the thing I
definitely rebelled against it if we're
going like trash versus no treasure
I definitely rebelled against it you
know I was uh there was there was
definitely some cocaine floating around
that high school you know what is here
baby like in the beginning it's like in
the beginning to kids in traffic that's
what I imagined you would Hugh and
Topher Grace hanging out for eBay I
wasn't
that was a great [ __ ] move ah man love
how much Foley loves movies so yeah I
mean it's funny people would always say
to me like Gossip Girl and that's how I
know the girl would be like too young
for me I'd be like I don't [ __ ] know
what you're talking about you know but
uh we I never did coke wines I've never
done in my life because I knew a kid who
[ __ ] this is dark here but I knew a
kid who like I was in public seventh
grade he was in eighth and he [ __ ]
jumped out of a window cuz he did too
much coke thirty stories even read he
was in a yeah so uh I know what you're
thinking he didn't make it but to no one
now that [ __ ] me up now that was one
of those things I was like oh man I'm
not touching coke and there was a
baseball coach in my school who was just
like the coolest guy and he would he
just liked me because I was a bad kid
and I think he just thought it was funny
he was like he was a rebel too but it
was like a stuffy private school and he
was like a vulgar Jewish coach he
sounded like he talked like George
Carlin that was the tone of his voice he
he would say [ __ ] like he would say [ __ ]
like he would say something racist in
class and then and then turned on the
black kids and go oh I'm racist I went
to [ __ ] Memphis 14 white guys hate
Christians one Jew yeah you're just
doubling down on the racism at this
point but you know yeah he kind of
steered me on a good path I mean I still
got [ __ ] up but it was mostly like I
smoked so much weed in high school I
drank so much in high school like I
really ate great on I was pretty bad
that's always where to meet you get like
where would you get beer like the bodega
is like you would find a bodega to sell
you or like first I mean you name it we
all had fake IDs on top of that he was
on the subway when he was probably
[ __ ] seven years old yeah that's true
we were and and raising so yeah we all
fake IDs if that didn't work you you
loiter outside of bodega and you look
for someone with kind eyes you know
there's always ways there's always
someone who know
I remember there was a Chinese
restaurant like a little [ __ ] called
Simon's which is like what Chinese
restaurant is called Simon come on down
to Mary's for her oh how I am Chinese
food but anyway we we'd go there I
remember and we would we wouldn't eat
Chinese we just sit down I'd be like Bud
Light plays always someone's parents
were out of town and they're like I mean
we were bad kids we found ways you know
I remember being like I mean this is
[ __ ] embarrassing you know but like
we would get in like dealers cars it was
a different time I would just get in
like him buy weed this is like when
buying weed was a big deal this woman
now have you walking into a dispensary
and it's just like oh yeah here you take
whatever you want they're like you know
Dan Soder has got that joke other like
Somali aids now
but like I remember I I go in there and
and my friend will be like [ __ ] he just
got in a car he's driving through the
park with this guy I hope he comes out
yeah no [ __ ]
we didn't know that guy and you're doing
it for a 40 of something called Sour
Diesel or have a little like it was
called back but uh yeah so we were bad
kids for sure I mean I what's weird is a
lot of the kids from my high school like
either had serious drug problems or
[ __ ] overdosed Jesus this is like
[ __ ] in the beginning of sleepers I
know you can't you can't even you can't
even say the kid that jumped off the
building is trashed though because you
said he was on the 30th floor
split-level you can't kill yourself
jumping off a nine-foot roof yeah all
right well let's get into some questions
here and I think I think we've geared
the questions perfectly towards the city
environment let's go I want to start
with some of the basics your mom's an
artist your dad's a lawyer was there was
there a maid involved that it made live
with you guys
weird a nanny
it was never looking all around like the
clock maybe we occasionally we had a
maid yes sometimes who was it
sorry I'm sorry was it the kind of made
that you would have to clean up before
they came or would they like comment
like pick up your laundry off the floor
my mom would want me to clean my room
before she came yeah that was respected
that like shell out another 20 bucks and
have them doing what are we doing it was
your mom cooking
yeah sure your mom cooked I I'm a decent
cook and it's because I'm not good but
like quarantine I'm living with a girl
who's like you know I'm gonna love my
girlfriend Taylor and she's uh she
smokes a decent man a pot or edibles or
whatever and she's also like she's vegan
- like eggs so she thinks anything I
cook is like amazing cuz the bar is
[ __ ] what the bars real low so it so
my mom can cook she's like she makes
like good good healthy meals she's a
healthy she's she's in great shape so as
my dad they're healthy so growing up
will you will you butterin or margarine
butter
okay did you ever have this is the did
you ever have this spray I can't believe
it's not butter come on dude I never my
mom would never buy it I went to my
buddy's house I was like what I'm like I
thought it was like Windex or something
I'm like I'm not [ __ ] putting this on
my toast I yeah you don't put on your
toast you do it for the guy because
there's something in ya like Pam or
whatever it's called the Namath now it's
all olive oil I only really yeah just
cause like a you put on anything where
the fleece is olive oil where was olive
oil in the 80s or 90s I didn't we didn't
know anything it was like vegetable oil
we were eating my parents like doing
doing vegetables and vegetable oil but
I'm like this weird taste is this yeah
you know the Mediterranean Sea I mean
they did it right for so long we don't
we act like we always say where the [ __ ]
was sea salt in our chocolate until like
five years ago
yeah you get up you got a chocolate bar
with a hint of sea salt
it's like $7.99 my [ __ ] best eight
bucks I ever spent it why can't why
can't Snickers or Twix just throw some
salt on there chocolate
it's char just ten more sense because
you know that's what salt cause I know
I make my girlfriend been making cookies
and was it I made them I must have
credit for her [ __ ] cookies she is so
[ __ ] good it's really good dude I
remember I remember when flips came out
like the first generic or the first
thing mass-produced like you could buy a
bag of chocolate-covered pretzels the
best thing about them is they left this
salt on they were like the only people
to ever keep the salt on she would I
would took my first bite of a flips yeah
school trip to like the Renaissance Fair
or something in their footage the game
as good as it gets for like a for a
snack what's like my favorite man
[ __ ] I'm obsessed with this new one
that's like they're like Hershey's gold
or whatever oh yeah it's got like little
pretzel pieces in the Hershey's it's
[ __ ] insane yeah we're only a couple
questions in Sammy's got some expensive
taste and that's [ __ ] where did your
mom go where's your mom go to the
grocery store in the city would she go
Zabar's was like a trees a boys was like
my dad would go running sometimes and he
would stop and Zabar's and like it was a
good treat if we get like like LOX and
bagels and [ __ ] that was like a that was
like a sometimes Sunday treat you know
that's [ __ ] no se no we went to like
she she would keep it like bangus tinos
yeah we did a little bit of we I don't
think we have a good go-to grocery store
I think it was like wherever there there
was a trashy one bias called associated
and we went there she was like this
place [ __ ] this place sucks
those are tough mainly associated yes
just like robots is a produce I'm like
what the [ __ ] I want to say this kids
not garbage at all because I remember
when I first came to the city and I went
to an Associated I thought it was like
the Taj Mahal associated trash it was
always like it was always rotten and
[ __ ] it's it's not a good go Surrey
store yeah it's all me the worst the
worst grocery store in the city as
everyone in New York should know is
Kristy Dee's without question yeah
because [ __ ] by the way I remembered
John Katz my TV's or whatever the guy
who runs it ran for mayor a few years
back he looks like a [ __ ] catfish
he's a little
if you don't know what he looks like but
Gristedes is like not only is it like on
the level of bad but associated it is
it's like whole foods back in the day
expensive like whole foods once Amazon
bought it the prices came down a little
at least now it's like [ __ ] Gristedes
is like expensive and horrible yeah the
only time I ever been I was living I
lived briefly in Brooklyn Heights which
is like super [ __ ] night you don't
even it's all just like millionaires and
[ __ ] and yeah
so it was that one that was that's what
was in the neighborhood so that was
really nice that was the only time I I
thought it was a nice [ __ ] spot to go
I didn't rise was Tracy it's your CDs
isn't crashy you're saying what are you
Steve it's just [ __ ] over
it's like insanely expensive okay it's
like they act like they're whole foods
and whole foods at least has some good
quality [ __ ] in there you know yeah well
he said Whole Foods like a rich guy here
he said that Whole Foods
look I'll [ __ ] go to any grocery
store at this I'm going to like
weird-ass ones in LA right now because
you just want to get the point now when
you're in LA like whole gardening coops
believe me I want to go to Whole Foods
more than ever right now but the problem
is like that's what everyone in [ __ ]
la that there's so many people like this
is the only grocery store I know of and
you're like no you got to go to the
[ __ ] [ __ ] grocery stores yeah
because those are the ones that have
everything it's untouched I got sick as
[ __ ] from going to one of the mainstream
ones Vaughn's
it now it's pretty good it's one of the
big ones here it's pretty nice but I
mean but that's the problem it's one of
the big ones so it's like I got I was on
my ass I think I had kovat Jesus it was
it was the sickest I've been in New Year
it only lasted like a day and a half but
it was like I was like 101 temperature I
was hurtin good immune system this
kidding garbage update right now it's
kinda hopin Flintstones ah yeah hook
down kovat in a day and a half that's
why I don't I don't have a good immune
system and I'm always sick I mean and
you guys know it is you want from the
road it's like if you're on the road
you're always saying so yeah I'm nervous
about this [ __ ] right here
yeah it's true you haven't been funny
you've been oh you've been over there
stay off of ICP
we'll still fly him yeah [ __ ] that yeah
but if they're with like the CDC fine
but anyone else what's the myth is
exactly I'm like what the [ __ ] are you
doing you see they're opening up the
they just announced carnivals opening up
cruises again in August yeah I tagged by
Macky and I said you could finally work
again dude cruisers were garbage before
this I used to Oh ever since I was a kid
I would see you know 2500 people sick
with bacteria on cruise ship we never
went we couldn't afford it but we were
never going on a cruise ship sir have
you ever performed on a cruise now I
wouldn't think I would go like I went on
that I only did one ended up Impractical
Jokers cruise that's the only one I
would do is like it's your with a great
group of people but it's still a [ __ ]
boat like I hate boats man I just I
don't like it it and also I think
everyone gained a hot 12 at least yeah
cuz there's food in every room you get a
check you're gonna like a banquet hall
room and you're like why is there fried
chicken in here you know trying to
fatten you up
it's weird that's why I did I would love
to do it just for the buffet man [ __ ]
hit the all-you-can-eat shrimp [ __ ]
there is it there's a basketball court
on the on the boat oh it is there's some
[ __ ] that you're like this is kind of
cool yeah
I've only ever seen commercials and I'm
like that's [ __ ] wild little head
like does the slide that goes into the
pool on the boat I'm like what this
slide goes over the side of the boat
underneath the boat that's cool yeah all
right keep me hit him
all right have you ever bought or sold
anything on Craigslist I've definitely
sold furniture on there I don't know if
I've bought anything on there I've done
a few times I've sold up on there for
sure yeah I bought software you had to
like go to their apartment and aslam
like every time before I walk in the
door like why the [ __ ] am I doing this
what am i doing
nobody's still doing that now right I
mean not Dorian [ __ ] cold I mean
women shorts [ __ ] don't
I thought Craigslist got shut down
didn't Craig those get shut down no I
think you can like a look at apartments
so maybe not I don't know I I know the
escorts got shut down that's that's what
I heard yeah yes what I heard - well
that
not all that's not the only thing you
use Craigslist for that's all you should
know before otherwise you're [ __ ]
garbage Sam have you ever ran down the
subway tunnels when you were a kid ran
down the tunnels yeah you watch really
oh wait no I in the tracks oh no of
course not big man on the train no God
my next question was have you ever
fought a rival gang member I'm watching
Seinfeld - that [ __ ] landed I just
went back a couple of weeks ago and did
it it's [ __ ] I mean I crushed every
season and like wait so good Sopranos in
Seinfeld are like my I'm so because I
talk I mean like you know a lot of feel
like especially comedians are you know
of our age and our generation
we're so influenced by the show Seinfeld
well my wife is from Europe so she's
never seen it so linked she started
watching she's like you've just been
quoting this yo she's like I thought you
were like coming up with all these lines
I'm just stealing from [ __ ] inside dude
my girlfriend's younger than me I made a
watch Glengarry Glen Ross last night and
she like 10 minutes in was like always
be closing is from this yeah pretty
great yeah that's awesome
all right so did you ever taking any
pictures down at the subway like you've
ever give any photos of like you and
your friends hanging out like on the
train tracks or down in the subways no I
never went on the tray I remember there
was a movie there was a movie I forgot
the name of it but like were they said
the third rail would electrocute you and
I was that was enough to scare me yeah
that was it I still believe that is true
that's I you don't [ __ ] with the third
rail that's 100% true I've obviously
seen people go down there but you don't
you always like good luck to that [ __ ]
and you better not get here because I
got somewhere to be you know as I can't
would you you would go from train to
train like be tweeting you know walking
from Bob yeah but that's I mean that's
really bad now but
people were telling me I mean people
still do it but that was that wasn't
like icepick a deal bag and I'm sure I
mean it probably was more dangerous back
then but she wasn't a strap-on did you
ever break dance on the train
well you one of the Showtime guys never
officially but I'm here to kick your
silly
yeah I mean we did silly [ __ ] on the
train but no never like never officially
did you ever sit out did you ever sell
anything on the trains did you ever sell
candy on the trains no never sold
anything on the trains I think this
guy's glass come on
I would sell [ __ ] on the street like
like like when I was a kid in summer was
like really young like lemonade and [ __ ]
but I would never do okay a young
businessman he's gets he's an
entrepreneur I like it Nevernever candy
now never got into the candy game on the
somehow I never broke into it Kippy have
you ever had Thanksgiving dinner at a
restaurant [ __ ] one year we did Chinese
food I think because something like
something went wrong with the turkey so
one year we did Chinese but that's like
it's a [ __ ] like I I wanna to I
wanted to admit that the second it came
out of my mouth because now we sound
like Jewish stereotypes that were like
[ __ ] - [ __ ] the UH [ __ ] the Thanksgiving
story [ __ ] the turkey let's let's get
some general so Simon's or whatever go
get some buzz lighten some [ __ ]
general Tsao Christmas Day Christmas Day
would you hit Chinese in a movie though
yeah of course I was always so jealous
of my friends that got to do that
awesome
mission do you know why these are the
only places open yeah well movies well I
think for a couple of reasons first I've
to get a lot of good movies that come
out of around that time of year so it's
so it's and like you're with your family
and Chinese is just like it's a
celebratory Jewish meal I think it goes
back to like a lot of Jews and an Asian
settling around the same time and and
Chinese being cheap but you know easy to
get and then just it just stuck with
Jews as like a traditional meal so
Chinese is the go-to for sure to this
day I love Chinese is following my
favorite I fancy Thanksgiving dinner and
I've always like you would see
the only time I saw the see that as a
kid would be in movies from like in New
York like people would go to have
Thanksgiving dinner at a at a restaurant
I blew my [ __ ] mind no no we don't I
think one year I think and it was cus
like the oven was [ __ ] there was some
dumb reason no we normally do it at all
yeah we would go to Boston usually some
of my dad's folks were from so we'd
usually go to Boston for Thanksgiving
nice classy again this kids hitting all
the buttons I'll pay that yeah all right
what about growing up what was the
earliest that you went to a strip club
in the city when did you go to scores
for the first time I know that was big
when you were a kid never been there I
went down went to one when I was like 18
or so know what happened my friend
Dennis growing up his dad was like he
was like a Mad Men character he was like
a [ __ ] I mean rest in peace he's a
great guy but he was a total party
animal and he loved us and invited us
one night he's like meet me at this
steak have my steak asses on 47th and
tenth whatever was that's not that such
one of those box that I should we my
friend and I Dennis we showed up in a
t-shirt like this a white t-shirt in
both in like cargo shorts and they're
like you can't come in here it was the
penthouse club and I'm a gave they
loaned us Penn House polo shirts to walk
in like that really cleaned us up oh but
uh you know one of the gypsies steal
your shirt and you couldn't get it back
we we go up there and anyway the dad was
like I got you crab cakes only time I
ever did was was in New York and we were
that's her party stumbling around all
day drink you know we started drinking
like 10:00 we made it to a strip club at
like 4:00 and I could like barely see
and I like looked in the
back and there was just like setup like
catering you know what I mean there was
like a couple of you know I don't know
tacos or something I just [ __ ] wrong I
can barely see I'm like I need to get
something in me before I throw up on
these [ __ ] strippers oh it's not good
I'm not I know I'm not a fan of it strip
clubs it's not my thing but I you know
yeah obviously it's like part of your
growing up processes yeah me you got 18
to 25 after that it's yeah it's rough
have you ever gotten into a fight with a
bouncer in the city
definitely not physically but I've seen
that and that does not look like it ends
well I've gotten in like arguments with
them for sure when you're like young and
had too much to drink but no no I mean I
knew my frame from a young age I'm sure
but have have you ever ordered a
screwdriver at the bar jeez I don't
think so and that's it that's a dead
giveaway you're either underage or a
piece of garbage if you're ordering a
screwdriver my move when I was underage
was to order a drink that made me sound
old so when I was like 18 I'd be like
give me a gin gimlet and they're like so
I would try to just order something that
made me sound like oh I'd be like [ __ ]
you know you can't order anything sweet
that's a giveaway they're young I'll
tell you you know who's go to drink was
a screwdriver slash from Guns N'Roses
if you're underage or a rock star you're
rockin drink whatever the [ __ ] you want
yeah yeah gimlet give me a Jim gimlet
and the TV Guide please thank you it's
only gin and lime juice but it makes you
sound worldly of course I just got a
little nervous here innit
dude I was at the Lancer the one time
and they thought I was on stage and like
these like five clearly underage girls
came in and they were like oh the wager
skimmers like what you want to drink and
she's like oh do you have anything on
special she's like oh we have $5 well
drinks they go okay we'll take three of
those you have no idea what a well drink
one time I was 20 I think and you know I
used to run this show with Harrison
Greenbaum was a magician you know and we
went to a bar after the show and he I
had a fake ID and he didn't and he takes
out a wallet and it just lights on fire
and the bouncers like all right go
inside he was impressed enough with the
trick that he was like all right you can
drink underage
nobody does that trick of us are going
through a divorce what was what was the
neighborhood you would go drink it to
like it was no like our neighbor was
like the East Village where there was a
bunch of shitty bars he could get in I
know there was a there was a bunch on
the Upper West Side too I think
yeah I know all those have been around
for freaking ever I think those were
like harder on IDs I think they were
like that was a rep I remember there was
a bar in the East Village called bar
none yeah that was easy to get into that
was like there was still there and I
think they still do shows yeah
did you comedy shows there yeah I think
in the back oh man how funny is that the
do stand-up at a place used to drink
underage it's [ __ ] weird I think I
might have done a show there once now
that you mention it but uh you know what
I mean when you you you start with like
hookah bars because they don't give a
[ __ ] and then you're like alright now
Chinese restaurants now let's work our
way up to like a shitty fake disco and
you made it like Scarface did you ever
go to limelight or any any place like
that or was that done by the time I
think that was it might have still been
around but it wasn't like a pop I was
not a club guy I never to this day I
hate clubs
I don't like places where your
personality is is taken out of the
equation
no I didn't I never had the confidence
to just walk up to a girl and like
present myself you know I needed to step
and don't what do you think sweetheart
exactly you need I felt like my only
change was to open it with something
funny so yeah I I was never an I'd been
to a couple but I was miserable I hate
Sam's picking up chicks at diners on the
Upper East Side when you go out to a
restaurant
do you ever order the special hmm that's
a classy move right there
is it I I usually don't I don't think I
am
I can't I'm sure I have my life it's not
my guy usually a my mind made up pretty
quickly I'm usually a I'm usually a
quick decision eater I mean yeah food I
can eat I appreciate good food but I can
honestly eat anything yeah you a chicken
fingers kid when I was a kid [ __ ] yeah
not anymore now it's like it's funny now
I used to get so excited by my unhealthy
food now I see [ __ ] fried food and
I'm just like [ __ ] I hate this [ __ ]
for so many [ __ ] years it was all the
clubhead when you got to perform for an
hour after eating fried food it's like
[ __ ] it's just not good yeah you feel
like you're like you feel like gas in
your chest you're like ah I feel like
coming out of my pores and my fingers
and stuff I'm like anything like I feel
the oil that it you know anything I feel
like I'm in the deep fryer after I eat
like french fries yes not extra virgin
either if I'm gonna eat like [ __ ] I
wanted I don't want to regret it it like
if I get like a burger like in-n-out at
least they're like Shake Shack at least
it's like a burger I'm not gonna like
regret you know yeah or I don't know I'm
gonna do fast food or something I wanna
I want to do it right okay all right I
got a I got a water for you I think this
is very garbage especially you being a
city kid Upper East Side ever in your
formative years date a girl who lived in
either New Jersey or Long Island that
you would have to go out and see her out
there and like maybe spend the night out
there god no no way
all right I believe you throw a
bridge-and-tunnel
is that right I believe I called it I'm
[ __ ] lazy is it like much I'm not
hopping on the path train or whatever
[ __ ] train I knew guys that did that
like I have family there I'll go see my
family but that's about it
all right growing up were you a shark
bites household or a gushers family I
love them both honestly yeah but your
mom buy them growing up my mom was very
healthy she liked if I had to eat us
I had to sneak a lot of sugary stuff
into the house my mom was very very
healthy I know I would buy them but I my
favorite like candies had things like
that I like showing through things were
like I love gushers I love shark bites
I love dunkaroos I love I love fruit
roll-ups fruit by the foot that was
obviously like cookies chips of Hawaii
for sure the best we would get is a
fruit roll-up we never got [ __ ]
gushers or shark bites were like that
was like Krueger ain't there was no way
we were ever [ __ ] seeing that Mouse
because we eat the whole thing I'd eat
that we'd eat the whole box really you
couldn't control yourself around sugary
treats you seemed like such a guy who
comes with self-restraint when it comes
to that stuff
all right that's neither here nor there
let's keep the let's keep working this
kid here have you ever ran out onto the
field at a sporting event God have I
closer like God was the dugout one time
we snuck down to the dugout and I got a
fist bump from Jorge Posada that was a
club we were like we were high up and
and be it was a blowout so the Yankees
are winning by a shitload and he was
already my favorite player so it was
like no I never got in the field but I
one time I got in the field was like on
the field day at a Mets game that my
friend and my friend took me to so that
was like the clothes not it doesn't
count I'm talking about streaking across
[ __ ] Yankee Stadium screaming Baba
Booey getting arrested close as I got
was that was a posada fist bump but that
was that was pretty big that's clearly
legit yeah I was a big fan so that was
pretty damn cool when you go to a game
do you go like was a kid or whatever
would you buy cheap tickets no me and
then knowingly try to sneak down yeah
yeah that's garbage
I like well yeah I mean like dude wait I
didn't like I don't know last summer
some went to a Mets game like just
because I had the night off my buddies
like we're going I'm like all right I'm
in and we win and we bought like the $17
tickets and the next you know we're like
you know
30 rows back or something out you know
on like the first baseline it was great
yeah good thing about baseball is you
get 162 games so like know who the [ __ ]
goes to every game you got to be like
insanely die-hard yeah nor have autism
one of the other yeah I never understood
what a security guys gave his shits like
it's the [ __ ] seventh-inning they
ain't coming I can't get up there I can
hang up yeah they usually don't give a
[ __ ] I feel like if the Phillies stadium
at the vet they were like they were like
[ __ ] FBI they like didn't want you
anywhere near the [ __ ] field it was
brutal dude this isn't talking about
that dish that just tricked this memory
how garbage my family is my uncle was a
cop and the Philly PD so four big Eagles
games he would sneak ACCA's Philly the
veterans stadium had a jail in it at a
jail and a judge and a courthouse is
like because so many people get arrested
they would process you immediately so
like you didn't have to like all shape
you to [ __ ] jail or whatever he would
take us in through the jail entrance he
would sneak us in and then we would just
like sit in the handicapped section or
something yeah it was pretty good
there's no view obstruction at all yeah
all right have you ever been involved in
or been to a topless or bikini car wash
no but I also like can't even drive so
car questions are like they're like such
a New York kid thank you I can't I have
a license but it was like I got it late
as hell and I got it she gave it to me
at a pity I went into the car like I
failed twice please don't fail me and
she laughed and I was like allow me I'm
good
so that was break the ice do you have
jobs growing up as a kid did you work or
no did your one call center a call
center yeah like cold calls yeah no I
didn't do that Kevin can you yeah that's
a tough one yeah definitely has
definitely been involved in some illegal
scams over the phone that I found outlet
after the second week I think
tried to be a knife salesman for like a
week and I just didn't have it I think
that's trash it Cutco knife salesman
buddy
that's king it that's the king of the
garbage right there I was young as hell
though I still had this voice so no like
I am selling [ __ ] you want some no get
the [ __ ] out here working with grown man
as a kid we've said this before it's
there's there's no better education when
you're like a fifteen seventeen year old
kid and you're working with grown
[ __ ] men it's like a real eye-opener
yeah unless you're Haley Joel Osment I
think I only got one or two more um do
you ever wear a chain wallet
never never you ever wear a jean jacket
with no sleeves have you ever had quiche
I love quiche garbage no heshes clean
living dude no you do make it the night
before what are you talking about yeah I
did I used to date a girl who would make
it a lot of quiche and I liked it yeah
it was good big fan have you ever owned
a futon yeah ever had a rat tail as a
haircut I would look like Frasier Crane
so no it wouldn't look like a rat tail
would look like a little curly poof in
the back of my head I'm getting it now
jeez Frasier was a great show I saw I
see Jerry's little like curly mullet on
Seinfeld I'm like that yeah that's what
would happen to me if that was that was
a weird because Jerry's uh he looks
really good now he's like aged really
well that's only well they all look so
nineties on that show that you're like
oh that's [ __ ] we that's what you do
with curly hair he didn't use ABBA Jerry
on a tight little body man remember the
one who should when he shaved his chest
he was pretty jacked and he never had to
put any product in that hair it was just
like yeah it was like naturally 90s yeah
do that
that shows just [ __ ] every time
Kramer just kills me like why did he
have to do that laughing I know you
heard everyone you heard everyone
involved when you think about think
about making a show that great like dude
the entire cast of The Cosby Show is
[ __ ] outta luck on royalties yeah yo
Cosby was a [ __ ] rapist you know that
like when reclaimer went on that ranch
ever
I was like don't [ __ ] up our royalties
yeah I know it's still I mean but they
still play it yeah I know but you never
know when if something like that happens
I'm sure some I'm sure some people like
I don't know yeah i i i i i wouldn't
[ __ ] even know where to begin that's
that's not how you take down a heckler
is what i would say well that's the guy
from cosby show that was working at at
trader joe's that was the reason he was
working at trader joe's is because [ __ ]
and they stopped running the cosby show
so his residual was dried up so he had a
[ __ ] take a regular job it's brutal
and constantly couldn't hear no [ __ ]
creep goddamn I know Cosby should just
[ __ ] give them that guy like a
million I know he's in jail oh crap
garbage is that how crazy is that the
thing Bill Cosby is in prison right now
and he deserves it it's not I mean I
guess you'd have to be that famous and
go away but like dude he is here's a
crazy thing about Cosby he's maybe the
most horrible serial rapist
more of our lifetime right yeah it's
crazy and was also America's dad at one
point which is you know and he also got
mad at Eddie Murphy for cursing yeah I
used to break his balls anyone who's
like holier than their than that you
have some dirt on them usually not
always but usually I still wouldn't mind
get my hands on a couple jell-o pudding
pops I'm not gonna lie to you that's
understandable
all right all right I just got a couple
more here have you ever you ever had
tuna casserole yeah I like it
what about sherbert were you a sherbert
family I didn't like sherbert I never
liked it yeah it's just like it's just
shitty ice cream and ice cream I love it
but I'm garbage and I'm really pulling
for you not to be garbage well I don't
think it's like horrible but like it's
just not for me I like ice cream I'm
also I'm also technically lactose
intolerant but I just fought it for so
many years that I'm kind of so you got
immunity to it I think I think I beat it
I think I beat lactose intolerance
my girlfriend is she is bad with lactose
intolerance we got like a bunch of oat
milk ice cream and the in the fridge I
got to tell you it's [ __ ]
good no it's not bad what's it the only
or something um there's one brand that's
like really [ __ ] good okay I'll tell
you what the best one is if you can find
it this is it is the van luhan's vegan
[ __ ] is unreal there's a $40 it's
expensive it's like colleagues they have
it at Whole Foods they have it at like
one of the grocery stores out here and
have it one of those like kind of nice
little grocery stores by me in New York
but it's like yeah it's [ __ ]
incredible
oh it's you better believe I check to
see if it was German or not I don't want
my [ __ ] Jewish blood community would
it be yeah yeah if you got anything else
I got just one more have you ever had my
degree have you ever had three be
Doritos that had never breathe all over
it
you don't remember those I remember them
but I don't I mean let me wait how long
me look it up real quick okay I want to
see what they look like so I can give
you a life time huge but like they were
like puffed up I'd be like kind of a
mini Dorito and then they puffed that
yep I've had this there wasn't gonna wax
coating in the middle of them they might
not [ __ ] good I gotta tell you I got
on board with some trashy new stuff like
I remember with Mountain Dew Code Red
King oh dude trash trash I'm all right
it's one of those ice-cold a nice 20
ounce and added some [ __ ] Turnpike
gas station do they still make it yeah
yeah they have like a blue one now too
yeah I remember doing a road gig like
nine years ago with a jealous and he
pulled over and bought a mountain Dew
and I was like really I didn't expect it
I was kinda like good for you because
I'm a coffee I do coffee for my you know
I do get ton of coffee now but like back
in the day when sugar didn't [ __ ] me up
like it does now it just makes like you
get that initial I which is great but
then like 20 minutes later I'm just like
I'm sad yeah Oh sugar does to me now I
get sad and I feel sticky I'm like I can
feel the sugar like coming out of my
pores that's so true yeah it sucks
Mountain Dews [ __ ] garbage man
[Laughter]
my last question for you Sam and I'm
gonna say right now no way this kids not
garbage at all oh wow all right Kippy
what do you think yeah you've got a
couple of blemishes in the file but
pretty Teflon just don't blow it here
okay Sam Morrell have they ever been
involved with Tiger Schulman karate any
karate school or this is the big one
okay
have you ever practiced karate in public
I did I did like kickboxing and when I
was a kid but it wasn't like a crowded
school cake boxing was cool that was
boxing was cool ya know because kids
weren't Agee in Central Park [ __ ]
working on his moves never never
I I feel like that's I hate that sugar
that's like [ __ ] learn it in private
and then dazzle someone when [ __ ] goes
there yeah exactly
you know I'm never into that I don't
like I don't like also like so many
people who just take a martial art they
take it for like two weeks and like let
me try this move on you know like yeah
that's not how it works yeah hit the
[ __ ] bricks work on the dummy for a
couple of couple of weeks before you try
it out on real people I hate the guys
[ __ ] practicing juggling in the park
I'm always like y'all take that [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] think you're bowling
pins somewhere I think no there's always
a guy in in in Washington Square Park
it's him and his girlfriend or him and
his wife tossing bowling pins back to
each other and I cringe every time I say
it that guy's gettin laid you believe in
it back if I told my girlfriend hey I
want you to take go out we're gonna
juggle together I'd be [ __ ] dropped
in two seconds dude he's looking at you
saying the same thing him and his girl
like you believe that guy that guy's
gettin laid right there the guy with the
nine chins and no teeth he's getting
laid
oh my god samer al not garbage buddy
thank you so much for joining us as
you're anything you want the folks out
there to know that they probably but
they might not already know I don't know
how that's possible I got a special some
Comedy Central's free it's uh it's just
Sam well I got this and I got I do too
podcast ones basketball ones movies I do
pot don't lie with Stavros and I do a
movie podcast with Taylor Tomlinson Colt
this is important to me we just like you
know any new couple you're like this is
that I like this movie you haven't seen
it you should have seen it we watched we
play clips it's pretty fun nice good I
like that
I'm keeping anything we're gonna no no
just make sure you go to your rate
review subscribe on iTunes we appreciate
all the new reviews are coming in all
the new subscribers also the full video
is available on YouTube please check
that out rate review subscribe comment
all that jazz and you can submit your
questions to our you garbage at
gmail.com yeah very nice and thank you
so much buddy we really from hell and
I'm talking to us we will see you guys
next time thank you so much this has
been our you go garbage
I made Foley goodnight thanks guys